vsauce kevin here with a game that
starts out easy but quickly becomes
impossible you can be the best in the
world at it
and still not get very far here
i'll show you the goal is to get one of
these
checkers to the other side of this line
haha i win i just won an impossible
game right wrong kinda
i won the uh i won the baby level but it
gets a lot more complex
than this your goal is to get these
checkers as
far over the line as possible there are
hardly any rules you can use as many
checkers as you want
and actually i got some empty spaces
here this checker set only came with 30
and that won't be enough
for my needs so i'm uh i'm not going to
use these
spit loop i'm gonna use poker chips
there's no limit to how many you can use
you just have to place them
under the line chips can only jump other
chips they can't just like
slide forward to an unoccupied space you
can't
and just do that they also can't jump
diagonally
but they can jump both vertically and
horizontally
so at least we got some of that sweet
sideways action
and when a chip does get jumped it gets
removed
from the board like that that's it
welcome to
conway's soldiers oh and this is a
one player solitaire game solitaire is
any one player game not just the card
game so
get ready to social distance your little
heart out
in the beginning of the video i used two
checkers to get to level one
it's almost just as easy to get to level
two using four
checkers it only takes three quick moves
and we've ascended
to new heights well done yet
still not all that impressive getting to
level three
is where it starts getting interesting
in 1961 mathematician
john conway invented this simple chip
game to prove
it wasn't as trivial as it appears
we can think of the chips as soldiers
trying to figure out how to penetrate as
deep as possible
into enemy territory getting to
levels one and level two wouldn't take a
whole lot of
soldiers or sophistication but the
deeper those soldiers
try to go the harder it'll be to arrange
actually it doesn't just become hard it
becomes
mathematically impossible which seems
impossible
if we have infinite soldiers why can't
we make it to
infinite levels first let's figure out
how to maneuver one soldier from our
tiny chip battalion into level three
you'll need at least eight soldiers but
you can do it in just
seven moves in this configuration you
essentially have
two separate forces the left wing
repeats what we did in the last game to
get a soldier
to level two and the right wing sets up
two volts to get our little rambo to
level three
you've gotta think about it a little bit
but uh
you're gonna get it for levels one two
and three it took two
four and uh hang on i gotta make some
room here hold on
i'm gonna try to move this without
ruining everything
in the world for levels one two and
three it took
two four and eight soldiers and we've
got ourselves a nice
two to the nth power pattern here
achieving level four should be two to
the fourth
power for 16 soldiers there also
seems to be a pattern on the number of
moves it'll take
as well if we call the initial number of
moves to get to level one
n then the level two seems to be
two n plus one two times one plus one
equals
three moves then we'll make n
that number of moves and put it into our
2n plus 1 algorithm for 2 times 3 plus 1
equals 7 moves yeah yeah all of this
works perfectly our 2 to the fourth
power
equals 16 soldiers will take two times
seven plus one equals
fifteen moves to reach level four
finally we've got a clean easy system to
get
to level four and beyond
right wrong this is where the simulation
breaks we actually need
get this we actually need 20 soldiers to
make it to level
four look slide this back on in here
i don't know i i did that voice well
can't take it back we create the same
starting pattern as we use to get to
level three but it'll end up one level
higher
then we play it out just as before and
launch our soldier to save private ryan
in level four
of enemy territory and it takes 19
moves not the 15 we expected everything
i
assumed was wrong our easy rule
on soldiers stopped working yet we
still found a way we didn't have a
formula for how many
moves we needed but we got there anyway
with the little
ingenuity from our five star general
me we conquered level four
i'm ambitious though like genghis khan
and alexander the great before me so
what will it take
to extend our vsauce2 empire
into level five
[Music]
five this board ends at
four i guess i gotta make my own board
sayonara puny
checkerboard
okay okay all right i did it here's my
custom
board and the first move that you need
to make to get
to level five is
nothing nothing works for level
five it's like trying to invade russia
in winter seriously it's impossible
impossible i'll even link you to a
website where
you can try for yourself it's so weird
having a limit
of four rows seems to make no sense when
i first
learned about this i thought this makes
no sense we have an
infinite number of soldiers and a board
of
theoretically infinite size it only took
20
chips to get to level four and level
five isn't that far how can we
not ever even get to level five
the answer is beauty
and taxis if we mark
our target on level 5 with a t
we can mark all the moves around it with
an exponent that shows how many steps
away that position
is it's the sum of the horizontal and
vertical steps to get there
it's the manhattan number which stems
from
taxicab geometry just like a taxi in new
york city has to drive across
a grid so do we and as we
map out the moves away from our target
we think about the three types of
possible jumps
ones that get us closer to the goal ones
that get us further and
ones that are neutral conway used this
weighting of each cell to uh
[Music]
to calculate um
need number file the mathematical proof
of why conway's soldiers can never make
it to level five
is explained perfectly by berkeley math
professor
zvezda stankova over at numberphile2 and
it's
42 minutes long it's surprisingly easy
to follow and along the way you'll see
how conway's game depends on the uh
oh no depends on
i gotta destroy my beautiful board
oh well
depends on the golden ratio the
proportions we see
in the natural world from flowers to
the composition of pretty faces and it
pops out of nowhere
in the middle of the game but it turns
out
we can reach the impossible level five
simon tatham and gareth taylor prove
that we can
get to the fifth row with a board of
infinite space
infinite soldiers and infinite moves
provided we
bend the rules a little bit all you
gotta do
is manipulate time
you really can go as far down this
mathematical rabbit hole
as you want but what started as a
simple solo lattice game morphed into a
metaphor
for both expertise and hope
with nearly everything we do the first
few levels are
actually pretty easy but as we aspire to
the more
elite tiers it takes more soldiers it
takes
more moves and a more sophisticated
configuration to reach
the top it takes hard work and
understanding and
just when we think we can't go any
further
ingenuity and creativity takes us to a
place we
thought was impossible on
april 12 2020 we lost one of the
greatest
mathematical minds of the 20th and 21st
centuries to the covid
19 virus john horton conway was
82 years old he talked once about an
object that existed not just in three
or four dimensions but in 27
digit number dimensional space
he called it the monster
he said these things are so
beautiful it's such a pity that
people can't see them well
maybe we can't i can't
but john conway helped us see the beauty
of
math in everything
even something as simple
as a checker and as always
thanks for watching
you